tentschuldigung wisst ihr wo die Comedy
Street ist ne wisst ihr wo die Comedy
Street ist ne die
Comedy wissen Sie wo die Comedy Street
ist oder ver Comedy ich würde ich nie
tun hier echt ist hier ja okay da muss
der Simon gr Johan ja auch irgendwo hier
sein stimmt irgendwo hier in der
Nähe neinider nicht schade aber er kommt
zu klicksum und dann wird er auch
erklären wo die Comedy Street ist
abgesetzt Sommerpause wir wissen es
nicht aber wir werden es sicher erfahren
und ihr werdet auch einiges erfahren
wenn ihr nutzerfragen stellt wie immer
lasst euch was einfallen kreativ sein
videoofrage Stellen Infotext lesen und
dann kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief
gehen viel
Glück